[Music]
recently congressional Republicans
proposed changing the tax treatment with
401k accounts that most Americans use to
save retirement instead of receiving a
tax deduction of 401k contributions the
tax plan would taxed these contributions
were allowed withdrawals to be tax-free
opposition to this idea was strong
enough that President Trump himself came
out against it on Twitter and when
congressional Republicans released their
tax plan in early November the idea had
fallen through entirely but what was
this all about some people were
concerned that without the upfront tax
break on their contributions Americans
would not contribute enough to their
401ks that's possible but other research
finds that most employees will keep
saving at the same rates even if the tax
preference changes this could increase
retirement incomes by having taxes paid
upfront and making the withdrawals
tax-free whatever the truth is the
Republican sponsors the tax bill made no
mention these issues instead they
focused on using the higher upfront tax
revenues from Roth 401 KS to pay for a
tax cut what do you think about how the
Republican tax plan would affect
retirement savings let us know in your
comments also let us know what other
topics you'd like our scholars to cover
in 60 seconds and be sure to like it
subscribe for more research and videos
from AEI